all right so again thank you very much
for having me had Singapore you have a
user group I'm here to tell you a bit
about about containers right then
because probably you are a Java
developer probably using a spring as for
spring boot as well and you're used to
package your applications jar files or
war files and when we package the
application as a jar file we probably
send these applications to the dev ops
team which will they basically run so
they have to gather the engine seized
they might have their gather things like
a a GRE oright or maybe a some container
or also probably they pass off commoners
to your application and that leads to
the works of my machine kind of thing
right because well the application works
in your machine but probably in another
environment you don't have the required
tendencies or you're running in a
completely different environment and
that's not ideal that's what we want is
to run the application in a environment
which is really close to what we have in
in development right so development
production should be quite similar
that's why probably a container might be
a good idea because in a container we
have everything we need to run our
application that includes the OS our
system the application system things
like how to run the application the
parameters that we have to pass to the
application so we can take this
container and run it anywhere right in
the same way so you can just build the
container yourself and send it to the
dev ops team and they will just need to
run this container but that need that
means that you now need to create this
container and well creating a container
might seem a really easy thing right but
you'll see that you'll have a lot of
power when you create this container
this is a way to create a container is
by creating a docker file and so that's
basically the easiest way to get started
and well you might say well I have this
a couple of lines here in our data file
and this gate gets me a container right
as that will create a container but is
this container the most article good
optimal container for you and for your
application so if we take a look at this
a target file so what we do is to
basically take a base image coming from
a dock open JDK and something implies
this
kind of give us GRE right old on Java 11
and then we just take the jar file from
our spring with application which is
copied in inside the detainer and we
define how to execute that application
Java manager and the application well
now you have a container so we could
stop here at our presentation you have
everything you need inside a container
but things are not as easy as we have
seen actually in that docker file you
can do whatever you want you can copy
stock you can download things you can do
whatever you want you have a lot of
power but we know that with a lot of
power comes a lot of responsibility so
we have to be responsible for a lot of
things for instance well the first thing
that could come into your mind is which
base image we should use and the base
image implies a bunch of things right so
it implies the operating system that
you'll be running on it also implies the
chocolates tribution whether you want to
also use a JK GRE let's have a version
as well until in three run a Java age
and 11 Java team alright so this is
basically the first question that comes
into your mind so we take a look at the
container that the previous docker file
will create and we expect it by calling
Dugger history alright so that will
basically tell you a little bit about
being layers inside the container
because a container has a bunch of
layers so you have the layers from the
base image usually these are with only
layers and as we as we see here in our
blogger history the first layers are
going to belong to ubuntu Bionic and so
which is 18.04 so this is basically the
operating system layers so it's
basically contributing some of the
operating system layers on top of that
we have the layers contributed by the
giri hotspot so that will basically
provide BG army to your container and
after that you will see that your layers
will be added on top of those base
images on top of these these base layers
so we take a look at the docker file
that we have created
single line will transform in a single
layer so notice that well we have the
from that basically contributors yes sir
GRE but then the Arts Park jar is
actually its own layer the copy is
another layer on the entry point is
another layer so let's take a look at
the copy one as you'll see here that we
have copied the entire jar and so that's
actually 18 max an inductor you can
actually reuse layers which are which
are below you that means that if you
change anything in your application with
that particular file you'll have to
rebuild the jar file and recreate the
container and replace the whole layer at
so you'll have to change the entire
layer because your application is a
single add a single deployment unit it's
a jar file this might not be ideal
because probably most of the mix here in
this chart file are going to be like
libraries so things that you'll be used
using which don't change so you'll be
changing your code but you would change
the spring version for instance so we
can do better by layer being a little
bit more these darker obtainer and if we
layer the docker container a little bit
more what we'll achieve is basically
faster builds because we don't have to
copy write the entire application
anymore and also when you deploy this
order you push the application into the
container registry you only have to push
the layers that have changed if those
layers are smaller this is going to be
much faster so in terms of bandwidth
we're going to save a lot rate so I'm
going to interview some of the features
in a spring put to the tree I'm in
spring food we have am a banana Gradle
plugin which basically creates the
artifact all right so here we have on
the left hand side the spring boot maven
plug-in which allows you to create a jar
file or files it basically creates this
Newburgh jar but now in spring boot to
the tree what we can do is to enable a
layered jar and so we are going to pass
these layers enabled Eagles through a
parameter and this will create an index
for the layers that we have in our
replicas
so we take a look at the content of the
chart file now that we use a layer jar
you'll see a file under boot - layers
idx that that's the index and this will
tell you the layers that you will find
in our jar and so we have a layer for
the dependencies we have a layer for the
loader we have a layer for the snapshot
dependencies and we have a layer for the
application itself so now we have
layered our jar when we have a our jar
layered what we can do is to basically
copy these different layers in its zone
or the different parts of the
application in its own layer and here
here's a more advanced a docker file
where we use multi built out our
multi-step docker file so the first part
is basically getting a base image from
the open JDK 11g hotspot and this is
only to extract the layers from our jar
so basically we're going to explode the
jar and extract the layers so this first
part of the docker file serves just as
the builder so we're going to just
forget about these part of the docker
file this base image and our container
will be created from these other base
image where we also ID except from the
base 11 GRE hotspot the base image and
we're copying some of the files from the
Builder which is what we have created
previously
so we basically extracted the layers and
we're copying those layers in its own
those parts of the application its own
layer in our container and then we're
basically changing the entry point to
use a jar launcher which might be better
than using Java - char so basically what
you could do right
in spring boo to that tree but if you're
not in the spring boot to the tree you
can still use it you'll have to
basically split your application copy
the up the different parts of the
application into different layers and
you'll end up in a much better docker
file so now if you change just one part
of the application you don't have to
push out all the layers
to the removal auditory or to build the
container you'll just have to take care
of the layer that has changed but you
have to take care of more than this by
default when you create a container you
will be running as a root user right and
we know that running things as a good as
a good user is not ideal so you should
take care of that as well inside your
container containers are not not VMs
that they are not security security
boundaries so you should run as a non
user and as a long root user you have to
understand how the build cache works you
have to also understand how the
multistage field works like we have seen
before you also have to be aware of tax
you have to also be aware of memory
allocation how much memory do you need
in your container and many other things
so you can find some of the best
practices on docker that come see we go
to double dot come we have an article on
some of the best practices that will
tell you how to build a docker file
right in a a proper way we go to little
called they will also have their own
best practices so as you see we have to
take care of a lot of things inside this
docker file so trading a an efficient
other file is not trivial as you'll have
to take care of it is image you'll have
to take care of multi-stage build the
user maybe you want to trim down the GRE
maybe well you have to do a lot of stuff
but well we are Java developers right
then for instance for myself I don't
want to spend time on creating those
containers on creating bugger files with
the best practices is there any way we
can get those containers created but
having the best practice wear spectacles
that we have seen well what option you
have is cheap so cheap allows you to
create a container without any darker
file so you have here the URL container
google container tools shape this
basically a tool that well has a maven
and a Gradle plugin you can add it into
your spring food application and it
we'll trade the container for you it
will use the distro less our base image
by default you can change that but this
will basically be the base image and it
will also split the application into
multiple layers at least at layers for
the application or the tendency and for
the resources it will also push the
image into a remote registry or into a
container registry and so usually the
way we expose this container is by
pushing that into a registry this could
be docker hub this could be a local
registry this could be yeah the registry
from from Google from aw yes so any kind
of registry right and the interesting
thing about cheap is that it create the
docker container without a docker
diamond which makes it really a good fit
for ci cities kind of environments where
you cannot what you don't have a darker
diamond in place and the version to that
for just came out last day right and it
has also an extension framework so if
you see that jeep is not enough and you
want to provide some extra behavior
right you can use the accession
extension framework to extend it right
with your own needs
so there's actually one option to use
cheap for a big container so you'll get
well-defined
container with the best practices and so
on alright another option would be built
box and if you have used Cloud Foundry
back in two days or Heroku maybe the
name built parks is already familiar to
you right
but in 2018 right the cloud native build
packs are the where created so that was
an initiative right to Center is kind of
the way we created those containers and
you can find the spec on build packs
so we go to build box that I yo you will
see that build packs a drea is just a
spec she doesn't have any implementation
on the specs that it defines
but the main goal is to end up having an
OC I container out of no docker file so
basically with zero configuration we
want to get an oceanic image and we have
multiple implementations of the spec we
have
implementations coming from Google from
Heroku from country we have also an
implementation called Paquito which is
what we're going to use today right but
of course every platform has its own
needs so that's why we have different
implementations of the bill pack
specification right but the main goal
here is to basically have or end up
having containers which are fast built
which have reusable layers and also that
are reproducible so if you recreate the
same each image multiple times you
should end up having the same container
right so the same input will leap the
same out I'd say we've gotten want to be
kind of deterministic here so we take a
look at the potato build box so this is
basically what we can either use today
so that's one of the implementations
provided by the cloud native sorry the
Cloud Foundry a team right there back in
the day to founder we had a bunch of
Bill packs all right so now we are
basically taking those field packs to
outside the platform so you can use them
on your maybe a local development
machine so anywhere else to build your
cleaners so picadome will have a bunch
of build packs if you take a look at the
Java build path you'll see that we have
built packs that will do a lot of things
for you for instance if you want to use
some kit this bill that will contribute
something to you if you want to use a
spring boot this will do something for
you as well for instance if you want to
use a GRE you can use the livery cab
bill pack for instance to get a GRE in
your container so we have a bunch of
bill packs available here and we'll see
how they work within our environment so
let's do a quick demo on how to build
our thinners and I have a really simple
application here it's it's not relevant
for the purpose of the demo but this is
just a springboard application it's
using the latest version of a spring
food to the 3.1 and it's basically
exposing a rest controller let's say
it's high data from from an endpoint so
let's a start and create a container out
of it so you have created a docker file
quickly get into that this is the
confounded we have seen in the slides so
we can actually create a docker docker
container out of these suckers file
that's what we're going to see first
right so we're going to first pack into
the application
so this will create my jar file which
are thought that we need to build this
container because the docker file is not
compiling my application we can do that
right but it's not doing it so I'll have
to create a jar file first and then I'm
going to create the container system
it's basically compiling passing the
test lovely and hopefully in the target
directory will have our jar file which
is this one here so now we can build a a
bucket container so we can pass that I'm
sorry we can find a tag let's call it
our spring s gene and we should go to
the previous directory so this is it
okay so hopefully this will get docker
file from the previous directory because
that's where we had the docker file I
mean it will start creating the doctor
quick so now if I do dr. images and some
are actually the one that we have
created is this one here and we could
inspect it is turian I will see that
well we have what we have seen that's
how we are going to see that the
different commands in our docker file
will translate into those layers so now
we can just run it speed 80 and we take
the image itself which is here and they
should run our docker container start
running
so we go to localhost 8080 I want to say
this in funny maybe I UPS
I just fir have a type of here I didn't
export the port correctly that would be
the easiest way to get a container at a
spring with container alright so we have
here hi
from Singapore that's great so now what
we have to do is to push that into a
container right so I have here a local
governess cluster and also a local
registry I'm using kind for that it's a
kind allows you to create a kinetics
cluster out of docker containers so you
don't need much this is great to run
locally and start your communities
cluster locally but now we'll have to
push at the base application into the
registry so I'm going to curl the
registry for a second so we have
actually a bunch of repositories already
in in the registry but the way to push
the limits to the registry is basically
doing dr. Paresh right and then pushing
that into the registry so I'm going to
keep that at service we have a bunch of
images already in the repository I'm
going to move into the next step which
is basically taking a look at the layers
so we take a look at the jar file that
has been created see that so what we can
do is to basically inspect the layers
that we have in here so we have here a
list command that will tell you the
different layers that we have in that
jar files as we see here we have a bunch
of layers which is which are created by
spring boots so remember that when you
use the maple plug-in with layers in a
both this will create an index file that
will create the layers for you so by
using the list command you can see the
different layers that your application
has you can of course create new layers
if you want and if you use extract
you'll be able to extract those those
layers and
in this doctor file which is the one
that we have seen in the slides and
basically using the extract command to
extract all these layers and then build
the different layers right in our
container but again enough of the darker
files because as we are we are Java
developers who maybe you're not
interested in building the docker file
yourself so I'm going to use jeep now in
order to create the docker file so I'm
going to do a maven compile and I'm
going to use the jeep docker build
command so if we take a look at the pom
file I have added Jeep into it let's
scroll down they have the Jeep plugin
which will create a container for me and
it's going to push it directly to my
local registry localhost 505,000
slightly spring boot SGG is going to be
my container name right so this will
push it to my local registry just by
using Jeep doctor build so let's try to
create a docker file with no sorry
doctor container with no doctor child as
we see here we are using the maybe I'm
planning for Tucker so notice that we're
using the thief's release base image as
we don't have any any bucket file so
jeep will choose the base image for us
all right so you could change that but
this is already chosen for us and it's
also splitting the application into
multiple layers so now what we can do is
to take a look at the built container so
if it's basically the build container
and a really nice tool to dive into the
container and see the different layers
that layers that we have in our
container is DYFS so you can do dive and
the name of the container and this will
give you like a pre visualization of
what's inside the container which is
really really nice so on the right hand
side as we see here we have the
different images or different layers of
our image so we're going to focus on the
three last layers so these three less
layers are nothing more than our
application notice that this layer that
I have selected is contributing is
the libraries of our application so on
the right hand side you can see this in
red so it's basically adding these
libraries which are 18 megabytes so this
is usually what will never change in
your application you'll probably change
your code but maybe you won't be
changing your libraries so that's why
this is in a lower layer than your
application code but if you take a look
at the second layer which here are some
some bytes these are just the resources
so for instance the applications of
properties that you have in your
application it's contributing this part
of the image which are the resources and
the last layer is contributing your coat
right so these are the application
classes here so this is the code that
you have great so we have classes
libraries and resources and different
layers so let's do one thing now let's
go back to our application let's change
something right so let's change our
class and let's say well I want to show
hi from blogger Singapore Jeep and I'm
going to build the application again
that's what I'm going to use maven
compile Jeep docker so I'm going to
compile it again
and hopefully this will reuse my
existing layers because we don't have to
change anything we just need to change
the layer for our application and this
will create yet another container so
let's compare these two containers now
give a little bit bigger
hopefully these will fit in one slide
okay all right so let's dive into the
new container and we'll compare the
hashes of every single layer right so
every single layer has a hash so we know
whether we can use it or not and let's
take a look at the three layers that we
have seen and now we're going to take a
look at this hash here this is the hash
of the container or the of the layer so
let's compare that with the other
container so we take a look at the hash
of that layer we see that it's the same
at
in both containers what containers have
the same layer that means that this has
been cash and they both use the same
layers but it's actually great because
these are the dependencies this haven't
changed so we could be used that layer
from the cache what about the resources
let's take a look at the resources the
resources has these hash down here so
let's take a look at the hash from the
second container at the new container
and we see that they are both the same
so we have we used the resources as well
but what about the last layer which is
our application so our application has
changed so we take a look at the hashes
from both thinners we see that they are
now not the same so this hash starts
with 29 8 this other hash starts with
FDF so the container just the first on
the last layer the the topmost layer I
notice that it's only 3.5 kilobytes that
means that if you want to push that into
the registry which we have done with
chip we have just pushed this 3.5
kilobytes we haven't pushed the entire
image which is correct right because
this leads to faster builds this leads
to less bandwidth so when you're
developing this is really important
all right so that's basically what we
achieve by layering the container lovely
that was a [ __ ] all right and when we
compared the different digests or
different hashes from the thinners so
the authority that we have seen is was
basically the build packs and in spring
boots to that tree we have a really nice
integration with the kill packs and by
default we're going to use the potato
build box so how can we create a build a
container right from the build back so
we have a command which is what maven
spring boot built image you can define
your image name either which will be a
local host 505,000 spring buddhist gym
and when i do that we're going to use vo
pack so you create a container let's see
what happens when we trade those those
containers well first thing that will
happen is of course building the
application compiling
past so that's a normal male build right
but after that when everything is
generated we have our charge files to
notice that we have here our jar file
we're going to start trading the build
back in in sorry the container in um in
boo box right now we don't have the
concept of a base image we have the
concept of a builder right so you'll see
that we'll be using a builder which is
by default a base platform API zealotry
and it comes from the potato build box
when you create the container more than
one build pack can interact or actually
participate in desk maturation of the
build back in our case we see that we
have five build packs that will be
participating when creating this
particular container out of 15 right so
we're basically creating what's called a
peel plan and the build plan will define
which by which build packs are going to
participate in the creation of the
container so we see that we have
something called Bell South America this
is basically a jury or well jump
distribution we have another pill pack
that will take care of the executable
jar
receipt and a spring boat correct so
well since that I have run these before
already so I probably will get a bunch
of layers from from the cache but let's
take a look at the different pillbox the
first real part that kicks in is the
potato BellSouth livery built back
notice that this will contribute in our
case a GRE and it will contribute a giri
which will be a jury 11 it's depending
on what you expect this could contribute
the ijk or GRE of course having a JDK
imperfection or in a container might not
be a good idea
it's a apart from being or the container
being bigger in size this is not a good
idea a team you know okay so probably
you'll need a GRE to run your
application but along with the GRE it
will start contributing a lot of layers
for instance the memory calculator
memory calculator is quite interesting
because it will calculate the amount of
memory that your container ha requires
are the based on a bunch of things like
the number of threads number of classes
that you have so when you start the
container the first thing that you will
see is the memory calculator came in we
have another layer another layer
contributed which will be that class
counter we have another layer which is
the JVM killed because when you run out
of memory your process might by being in
an inconsistent state so the JVM kill
will be an agent that will take care of
killing your your process so it can be
recreated by kubernetes a for instance
we have the local DNA s so that's
basically a local DNA is because well
the JVM when it resolves an address it
caches that address well forever right
so this will basically have a local DNA
so you can interact with resources that
have or change the IP frequently like in
in committees right there where we have
different pause different resources that
change the IP frequently and you don't
want to catch those resources we have
also job security properties and
basically certificates so you'll see
that we have a bunch of flee yours added
to the container that will give you a
lot for free let's say we compare that
to the first of our file that we have
created but the core file didn't have
anything so it lacked a lot of things
and another thing that where the bill
packs will do used to create a user so
you'll be running your container on
another user which is not the root user
so we have a GRE so now we have this
executive all char Bill pack that will
add the the the entry point all right so
that's basically how we're going to
execute the char file we have other
build packs that will contribute also
for instance the springboard Bill Park
and many of the bill packs I noticed
that all of them will basically
contribute in different layers in our
container all right so we can I see that
in a second and eventually we'll get our
image created which is this one here so
let's take a look at the image that we
have created with the Frasers mentioned
that is a really nice tool to instigate
the image as we're gonna use dive I will
see the different images that we have
different layers that we have in our
correct so I'm going to jump directly
into some of these layers let me just
change the filters here and just filters
and I don't want the and what I fight ok
so let's take a look at the visa this
one here right so this is basically the
layer where we see that the build pack
adds something into it all right so this
basically it's something related to
their lifecycle but eventually you'll
see that the build park already a
contributor on some players so this is
the class counter this is basically the
Java security properties this is the GRE
so notice the size of it so 140 is
basically the entire GRE then we have
another layer which contributes the JVM
kill HMS we have mentioned another layer
that will contribute the local team is a
layer that will contribute the memory
calculator and so on and so forth until
the last layers which basically use the
layer jar that we have seen to sleep our
code our code in two different layers so
notice this layer it's 18x and it
basically contains the libraries of our
application then we have another another
layer which basically has the boot
loader we have another layer which has
our container our code right so we have
everything layered in its own layer as
we have seen in the jar file which is
really nice and so they know that they
will end up having a container with high
standards we have a container which has
like multiple layers for our application
but also contributes or has a bunch of
things that will make our container up
and ready at for native our cloud native
deployment which is really really nice
alright so far so good alright so now we
have our container now that we need we
know how to build a container different
ways to build a container
of course Jeep and bill packs are doing
a great job
building those containers but sometimes
we need to go back to dr. Crouch the
doctor files are really really flexible
right so if sometimes you might need
more flexibility and other files are
also an option so bill packs are not a
replacing a bucket file sometimes it's
really nice ways to get the container
done or created but sometimes if you
need more power you can go back to the
doctor fast but you'll have to take care
of everything that we have mentioned
before great so now you have the
container and so you're ready to
distribute that container so hopefully
you have pushed the container to a
registry and now we can run this
container somewhere you could use docker
run right so you could run your
container that's just locally we could
do that but probably in production you
will need some kind of orchestration all
right so you will need to observe your
containers to check whether they're
available whether you want to scale
those containers the application you
want to have some operability and
maintainability and many of the things
and so just running your container
maybe we thugger compose or any other
tool won't be enough like so when you go
to production maybe you need some kind
of a container straighter and this could
be given at ease in our case it's so
well the premises of kubernetes are
really nice so you get a platform where
you deploy the application it's going to
be customer later then the platform will
restart be the depositor that containers
that are not life and so on
but when you get into your Nettie's well
someone will tell you that kubernetes is
great but of course it has a curve and
so well I you basically see a lot of
articles on the internet telling you
that Terminator ZC is great it's easy to
get started and then when you get into
committees you will see that well you
have to understand a lot of things like
what a comfort map
it's what a deployment is what a service
is what are the what this airbag or the
system volumes or many of the things
that's it has a learning curve as well
so I'm not going to try to tell you what
cure my disease but at least I'll tell
you a little bit about the bits and
bytes that we'll need to push our
application in to cover Nettie's so so
far we have what we see here we have a
container where we have our application
probably we have layered our application
and we have pushed our container into a
container registry let's mention this
could be docker hub or any other
container registry which is out there
but in kubernetes we cannot simply
deploy a container so the smallest
smallest unit of deployment is a pot a
pot will contain your your application
your container actually in a pod we can
run multiple containers but but usually
we have a one-to-one mapping between
your application and a pot right so
again you can have multiple containers
but this is going to be the deployment
unit and the scaling unit as well so if
you want to scale you'll be scaling a
pot an entire pot that's why well having
things like a database inside the same
part as your application might not be a
good idea because when you scale your
application will be sealed is killing
the database as well as usually have
this one-to-one mapping into the part
but this container rather this part
needs to be replicated at the end of the
day having single a single instance of
the application won't be enough in
production so we'll be creating a
replica set and the replica set allows
just to be find the replication of the
application you can decide well I need
three instances of the application so
the replication will be free in our case
and this will take care of our
containers or our pots it will basically
check that the current state is the same
as a desire state if we mentioned that
we want a three three instances of the
application and there are only two
credits are
the platform will automatically create
an extra pot for you an extra instance
of the application for you so it will
make sure that you always have the
number of replicas that you need but
really you'll be creating a replica set
by its own either a pod by its own so
you you never create a part by in zonin
it's it's rare you can do it but but
usually what we create is a deployment
and when we talk about pods or replicas
sales or deployments income for that is
that translates into a llamo file right
so we have to go back to writing some
files so in inductor we have a void
crime avoided writing these soccer files
by using genie poor bill packs but now
we have to go back to llamó and create
the pod definition or the replica set
definition or a deployment definition so
usually we'll be creating a deployment
definition that will define the number
of replicas of your part I will define
also the containers in those parts so
the base are the images in the registry
and so on great but now when we have the
pods up and running those parts are not
going to be busy fall outside so they're
going to be local in inside the cluster
but if you want to make them visible to
the outside you need to define a service
we have different types of services
right if you deploy that into a
equivalent is a provider like a gke
right this could be a load balancer or a
locally this could be simply an exposure
off we're basically defining an IP that
will expose those spots so Silvia is
nothing more than a way to access your
ear pods because by default there will
be internal and you won't be able to
access them so we need to create a
service to interact with those spots
correct so in spring but to the three we
have something called the liveness or
actually the concept or also
interpolators we have a kind of buff of
liveness and what is what do we call
that a part is alive right so basically
when the internal state of that part of
the application is valid and so we
basically started the application
everything is valid and we can basically
say that the application is up and
running right so when the aliveness test
or
prop says well we are not alive so
something wrong is in the in the
application what communities will try to
do is to restart container so the
lightness test or the the probe
basically says well can we restart the
container and get a contain a plication
life and in a validate state and so
basically it answers this question if
we're starting the part or the container
will solve the problem then just say
well I'm not alive right and in
is a lightness probe or actually check
usually don't interact with external
resources right because let's imagine
that you have a health check against a
database and you make this part of your
life let's check what will happen is
that if your application is up and
running and your database is down
Cavan edits will try to restart your
container but this can deal to cascading
failures because if you have more than
one instance of your application it will
this will start with starting all the
parts all the containers that you have
just because your database is down so
usually that's something that we check
without external systems and in
Springwood to the tree we have an end
point at check for the likeness of the
application so back in the days when we
didn't have a spring boot up to the tree
we usually set the likeness of probe to
slogic twitter / info but now we have a
specific end point for that called
actuator health-wise means we have
another concept which is the readiness
so you could be up and running but maybe
you're not ready to accept traffic so
let's imagine that your application is
up and running but you are building the
cache maybe it's from from another
resource so while you're building the
cache your application is not ready to
accept traffic so when you're not ready
to accept traffic your application will
be removed from the services so no
traffic will be routed to your
applications right so you have to be
real careful on what you define here in
the redness check either probe we have
some recommendations but at the other
day it's basically hue that define what
makes your application already right
better than ever day
this needs to be something that you
define I don't we'll see that in a sec
so in script 3 as we have the concept of
lightness and readiness inside the
application we have a couple of
components that there will be part of
your application context that you can
use to change the lightness and the
redness estate we have a couple of
objects called various estate and life
as a state and by injecting or getting
an instance of the application
availability right which is already in
your application context you'll be able
to check the liveness state and the
redness estate if you want to change the
live native state and red mesa state
inside your application what you can do
is to emit an event by the other day
when something happens in your
application let's say well
I'm building the cash you only know when
the cash is ready or yeah when we have
ended building this cash so at this
point you can send an application event
and change the state of the application
from unready to ready and you can do
that with this availability availability
change event so let's take a look at it
in a second so I have here a cluster I'm
just plugging into the cluster with this
token I have here my local cluster right
out which that doesn't have much you see
here that we don't have any deployments
we don't have any parts we don't have
any replica sets and what do you now is
to basically take the the the docker
container that we have created and push
it into kubernetes so for that when we
get what we'll be creating is basically
a deployment let's go back to to our
terminal
and I'm going to create a folder called
ha Coop's kubernetes just forgot the s
but anyway and I'm going to check the
registry first and let's see what we
have in there let's see what we have
here curl catalog all right so we have a
bunch of of containers so I'm going to
put one of these containers directly
into cover Nettie's by creating what we
call a deployment a deployment is
nothing more than a llamo file but as
mentioned we might not be willing to
create a Java file so what we're gonna
do is to use the keep CTL command or
chip kettle or chip control however you
call it to create a deployment at
implicitly either interactively without
having to trade a llaman file we can do
it by using the clips of the upgrade
deployment I'm going to specify the name
of the deployments priyamvada stream and
the image of the deployment which I'm
going to
use local hoods I find with spring food
SG built back and notice how I'm using
this - oh yeah no so that basically
generates the output llamo as Yama file
I'm going to use this dry run dry run
simulates the creation of the deployment
it's not sending that into our
kubernetes cluster it's basically
simulating that we create that
deployment so that what this will do
used to generate the Yama file
corresponding to a deployment I'm going
to pipe it to deployment dot job crate
so hopefully we have the deployment
created so let's take a look at the
ployment channel so that's basically my
deployment so we see the name of the
deployment we see a label we see the
replicas as well so by default get one
replica of the application and we see
the container that we're going to push
into one of these parts so now that we
have the Yama file what we can do is to
keep CTL apply - f and we pass the the
ployment Yama if we take a look at the
where cluster let's put it here and we
deploy that will see that the pods will
be created so notice that by deploying
or applying the deployment we have a
deployment created but also a pods
created and a replica set created right
so remember it's a part is basically
there's mullet the smallest unit of
deployment but we have to define how
many replicas we want and we also define
the deploy so now we have one pot and as
we see here well this is basically
having our container this is running our
application internally and what we could
do is to change the deployment so I'm
going to change the deployment and say
well I need more than one replica I'll
be or I want three replicas I'm going to
deploy that or apply that - F deployment
of Jamo let's just move to here for a
second let's apply that and let's see
what happens so here we have one out of
one but notice that automatically these
will create two other pods right then it
will basically start
our application now we have three
different parts containing our
application but these parts are internal
we cannot access them as mentioned
before so we need to create a service
from it quite another thing we can do
just real quick is to try to kill one of
these spots let's say I want to kill one
of these parts and just because we have
the replica said we have to see this
spot being recreated so I'm going to
delete this resource from here I'm going
to quickly move into the overview and
we'll see that well we have two out of
three parts and these will automatically
will delete the part that from from
primark
cluster and then deploy then new one and
so yeah so now we have the three of them
up and running so we have detected that
one of them was deleted but we needed
three parts we have we created a new bot
okay so now let's get into creating the
service so are we going to use the same
approach we'll be creating the service
implicitly without creating a llamó file
and we'll do cube CP I'll trade service
and we have different types of services
will create a service of type cluster IP
that will create a basically an IP
either inside our cluster or to
basically interact with our with our
parts but this could be a load balancer
if you run within a GK AE or any other
platform and we're going to again add so
generate the demo and we'll do a dry run
so that means we're not going to send it
to the kubernetes cluster or basically
simulate that and send it to a service
called a file called service dot and ya
know all right so now we have our
service and the service looks like this
so it's basically getting access to our
parts so we'll need to apply CTL - apply
- f service we need to apply the service
let's take a look at the service is real
quick and when we apply the service will
see the service are being created here
that's our created service
and notice how it basically has the
three parts accessible so that means
that if you use the IP of the service
they'll be able to access one of these
parts or any of these parts but as we
are locally what we need to do is to
forward the port from our host machine
into the ports of our service are we
going to do a port forwarding for that
just let me open a new terminal so we're
going to do a port forwarding for that
so we're going to do keep CTL port
forward services spring boot and we're
going to map 8080 to the port 80 so
hopefully let me check too many windows
here tops let me check the name of the
service service was called spring boot
as cheese business too much the service
okay so hopefully the port forward will
work now and when we access here on our
machine localhost 8080 so they should
actually get into one of the parts and
so when we hit that we are actually
getting to one of the parts in our
governess cluster
all right so let's take a look at the
lightness and the readiness probes in
spring put to the tree as mentioned we
have two special end points that we can
configure to basically define what is a
life application and a ready application
so if you use this management hell that
probes that enable equals through you
label those couple of end points if you
deploy out into communities these are
already yeah enabled for you but if not
you can explicitly enable them by using
this property remember that we can
change the readiness and the life names
by using something called the
application event publisher so I have
here a class which is nothing more than
a res controller which is exposing a
port an endpoint called change redness
so the only thing that this will do is
to get the current current state so it
will check the current resume state know
is that I'm going to use the application
availability which is also in the
application context I'm taking it I'm
checking the veterans of State and if
this is equals to the application
accepting traffic I'm going to change it
to refuse it refusing traffic and I'm
going to publish this event so by just
bubbling publishing this event we're
going to change from a ready state to an
on ready state and that will make our
part available but it wouldn't get new
traffic into it which is quite
interesting so what do we need to
configure the the props are the
readiness and the lightness props in our
kubernetes cluster or deployment so will
be see I will say it here I'm gonna go
to the deployment and I'm going to add a
couple of properties right which are the
readiness and the aliveness that's here
you go so I'm going to set the redness
to a quitter slash health of readiness
and the aliveness I could have slash
held a slice of lightness
I have changed my
so I'm going to basically apply this
deployment real quick give CTL apply and
safe deployment and hopefully that has
changed might change my parts
okay so let's wait a little bit they
have something wrong here actually
right because that should be already up
and running
apparently ID
something wrong in my deployment
probably probably something wrong in the
identity of this check that so Michael
how are we doing with time it's okay but
there are like quite a few questions for
you as well okay so maybe you can move
on and leave some time for questions
just a couple of slides I don't think
that Springs boots to the three
introduces is the graceful shutdown so
at the end of the day if you have
ongoing requests and you say I want to
terminate a part you cannot leave those
requests unprocessed all right so you
want to finish with those requests and
then terminate your application and it's
called graceful shutdown at that point
you don't want to accept new requests
but you want to wait until everything
has finished right and that's basically
the gradual graceful shutdown which you
can enable in spring boot to the three
with server shutdown graceful and
additionally you can define how many
seconds you want for a grace period that
works for all the server containers both
for the server stack and the reactive
stack so you'll see that when you
terminate your pod the pod won't be
killed you'll have the Chris period to
terminate or to finish with the request
and then your part will terminate all
right so that's really nice so you don't
have ongoing requests at an unprocessed
unless thing I wanted to show you but
that we didn't have time to do it the
other day when you are the developing
you basically go through this build
deploy refactor kind of a cycle you
build your application you have to or
actually you change your application you
build your container you push it into a
registry and then you have to deploy it
into kubernetes alright and this takes
over sometime and you have to maybe
apply the our create a container apply
the deployment again and many other
things so what you can do to be faster
well the point is users careful
shuffle allows you to monitor your your
source code so when you change the
source code it will automatically
compile the source code created the
image for you deploy it into cuber
Nettie's and you can see the application
up and running into your governmentís
cluster so this will simplify a lot why
did your development for sure but you
can also use a scaffold for your
production environment not only for for
development so if you have liked what
you have seen today right I recommend
you to check out this couple of
workshops that's a really good workshop
or from Ryan Baxter and a tire on a
sprint kubernetes this contains a bunch
of the things that we have seen today I
said how to create lia applications with
that bill and their containers filled
bags how to deploy that you need to
govern it is the liveness probe the red
means probe and all this stuff it
scaffold and customize and many other
tools actually the kubernetes
environment you see is huge right so we
have a lot of stuff so you'll see it is
actually a really nice workshop to
follow and then we have another one from
by a big hire as well called kubernetes
intro which is also exposing or telling
you a little bit about all these things
right so they're really similar but the
I would recommend you to follow both of
them they're really detailed and they're
great understand how to deploy your
applications into kubernetes and with
that I think that that's everything from
my site